[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bryce congratulations when do you start
preparing for cincinnati
thank you i really appreciate that um
we're back to work as a team on on
thursday and then i mean obviously
that's when we start you know putting
our stuff in um coming back together and
um you know that that's really when we
start to lock in okay uh where is the
heisman right now
i'm still in new york uh still in new
york city
do you have it with you
no um i think they're they're working on
transferring it
um back i like to
i'd like to say honestly i'm a little
absolute but
um yeah i believe they're working on
transferring it back
have you been to new york prior to the
high are you still in new york
yes yes i am they won't let you out
no uh um we just had a we had a couple
more days for um of breaking i just i
just stayed up here until i get ready to
get back to tesco's just so that we can
get back to work okay what did you do in
new york that you always wanted to do
um i went to a knicks game which was um
you know which was really cool
it was it was great to
to see the garden i'm a big basketball
fan so to see the garden and and
you know watch watch nick's play was
always kind of something i wanted to do
so it's been fun no you gotta go tonight
yeah yeah i'm uh
yeah i'm working on that that that's the
um yeah i'm actually working on that
okay bring the heisman and then you sit
in the front row and then you say hello
to steph curry
i mean
come on
yeah i know that
that sounds great um that that would be
not that that would be amazing i'm uh
yeah i'm working on trying to get to the
game tonight so uh hopefully hopefully
i'm able to experience it the last
watching uh last game was was was great
so hopefully i'm being able to do that
again tonight uh what did coach saban
say after you found out you won the
heisman
um you know he was he was super
supportive um
you know he he's been it's been great to
be able to you know share this weekend
with him and um you know he was super
supportive you know
a lot of congratulations and you know
when it's obviously this isn't coach
saban's you know first time in new york
and in the weekend like this but for him
to be so supportive with me and be so
enthusiastic um it meant so much to me
all right is he going to
yell at you just so you don't have it
too big of a head after winning the
heisman like how does he bring you back
down to earth bryce
yeah yeah well we we both understand
that you know this is a huge honor um
and a huge blessing to receive this
award but you know at the end of the day
this isn't you know this isn't my goal
this isn't our goal as a team and
there's still a lot of work to be done
um so you know obviously that's on
myself to to you know make sure that you
know the the main thing continues to be
the main thing and um you know it's
going to take our all
um for us to you know be successful next
game is going to take the best
preparation is going to take everyone to
be bought in so um you know there's no
room for me to um you know let this
award change anything or change how we
think um we've had uh former alabama
players on and they all tell the story
about coach using the expression deez
nuts
is that still going on bryce does he use
the expression deez nuts to you
yeah if you're you know if you're not
careful he'll
you know he'll flip it in
every once in a while
if he's in that mood so you know you
always got to keep your head in the
swivel oh
you know josh jacobs is the one who
first told us this story uh derek henry
had to uh confirm it and so did tua
they're like yeah yeah coach says you
know dee's nuts you know so
you're quiet here
no it's i mean there's nothing nothing
there
they sound like they got it right
it you know
just every once in a while you know he's
just in good taste but you know you just
you just always got to be on your toes
is he funny
yeah yeah you know obviously it depends
on the scenario coach saban is you know
intense and practicing watch what's best
for us so he's pushing but um you know
sometimes off the field or you know
maybe sometimes in flex warm-ups
you know he'll he'll be cracking a smile
and and tell a joke um here or there and
so yeah coach coach saban definitely has
that funny side um so it's always good
you have a coach that can you know kind
of read the situation know how to turn
it on and turn it off what was it like
when you announced that you weren't
going to go to usc
and you were going to go to alabama what
what was the local reaction with uh with
friends that you were going going south
and not staying staying home
yeah it was it was tough you know um
you know with being
so close to the university
and being committed there for a little
bit
um
you know it felt like a lot of things
you know i had a lot of things planned
and a lot of things accounted for and it
was definitely a comfortable option
and you know a lot of
you know a lot of friends of people
around me um you know it was it was nice
you know just a concept of you know
feeling like you're not leaving and feel
like you're still going to be around and
you know when when i decided to leave
and attend the university of alabama
you know that kind of goes out the
window
so it's you know it it's tough for you
know stuff for myself it's tough for
everybody and kind of that reality of
you know being so far from home you know
kind of begins to set in
and you know there are people that are
disappointed and um you know people that
you know chime in with their opinion and
you know that that's understandable you
know everyone obviously is going to have
an opinion on the matter but um you know
for me
it was all about doing what was best for
me um you know pushing myself to be the
best and um it was clear that alabama
was the best option so
you know that's what i decided to do and
it's been the best decision that i could
make now obviously you're great at
football winning the heisman but
how much of this is about business as
well with the name image and likeness
and you've been very successful in doing
that but do you view yourself as a
businessman and a football player
um you know i think there's certain
times and places for that um right now
um with the season still going on and
so much for us to still accomplish and
so much you know work for us to put in
in order to accomplish our goals you
know i'm i'm focused on being you know a
football player and and focused on um
you know just doing what i can and doing
what's best for a team and doing all i
can to contribute to our ultimate goal
um i feel like there's a time and a
place for for everything but right now
it's and you know we have a little break
but you know there's there's such big
things ahead of us um you know my mind's
not on any of that stuff right now 43
touchdowns four interceptions uh
what
give me those four interceptions
what happened
what yes that's a good question um
yeah let me let me think if i can do you
remember the four interceptions
um i probably
see i probably could remember
that's one two
yeah i mean all four interceptions were
just
you know just
just you know for me just plays you know
plays i wish i could have back
um
who they come against
what was it um
it was southern miss
um
ole miss
southern miss ole miss
um
a m and auburn okay all right
yeah you know just just throws you as
you can have back and you know it's
you know any time you turn the ball over
you know that especially as a
quarterback um you know that's
that you know that that stuff is not
supposed to do so um you know all those
stuff you wish you couldn't have that
stuff that you know
that you know i'm i'm still working on
improving and getting better at i mean
it's not bad i mean it's 43 touchdowns
but it is four interceptions bryce and
you know we can't accept that i mean
coach saban is not going to accept that
coach and i cannot accept that
no it's it's definitely learning points
and and stuff to go off no i was just
kidding i'm kidding i i can accept it i
don't know if coach can
but
uh what happened for 59 minutes against
auburn is what i want to know bryce
yeah you know we uh you know we we
struggled a little bit offensively
um and and you know there there was
stuff that you know we weren't we were
executing at the high school but i feel
like for us to you know have that
struggle um face that diversity and then
to be faced with a moment like we were
at the end of the game and for everyone
on the field to elevate their game and
to
to to step up to the occasion and have
the drive that we did as a team i think
that speaks to all to you know the
entire offenses and the entire team's
resiliency and then you know to carry
that on into the overtimes and you know
end up winning such a touch so it's a
tough and intense rivalry uh against a
really good team i think that that
really speaks to our resiliency our
resiliency and
um you know how we you know how we've
we've grown in
and you know gotten tougher in those
moments
good luck getting the tickets tonight to
see steph curry like that's that's uh
that should be your game plan today
yeah yeah
i appreciate that maybe you get to shoot
around a little bit with steph if you
get there early enough a couple of
jumpers what do you think
i would just learn to let her watch that
one i feel like he's probably got it
well i i've seen it so i like he's i
know he's his process a little more
private than allowing me to join but
you know just be able to watch it be
amazing uh congrats and good luck
against cincinnati and thanks for
joining us bryce
thank you i really appreciate that thank
you for having me on that's uh bryson he
is uh
he's made i think a million dollars in
name image and likeness